Salut, moi c'est Guillaume Hachez. Vous écoutez Septante Minutes Avec. Cette semaine, je reçois Morgane Delaisse qui est journaliste et qui a longtemps été expatriée en Chine.
On parle beaucoup de la Chine. Parfois, on en parle comme d'une dictature qui ne respecte pas les droits de l'homme. Parfois, on en parle comme d'un pays qui est plein de mystères.
Et globalement, on évoque souvent une culture qui est très différente de la nôtre et un rapport à l'autre qui est pas du tout le même que chez nous.
Bref, j'pense qu'on est nombreux à se poser beaucoup de questions sur la Chine. Et c'est pour ça que j'ai fait appel à Morgane qui a eu la gentillesse de m'éclairer sur toutes ces questions.
Une dernière chose avant de se lancer dans l'épisode : les premières 30 minutes sont un peu rudes parce qu'on tente de faire ensemble un résumé de l'histoire de la Chine.
En vrai, ni elle ni moi ne sommes des historiens, donc ça vaut ce que ça vaut, mais j'estimais que c'était important pour bien poser le contexte.
Voilà, c'est parti. Je suis aujourd'hui avec Morgane Delaisse. Morgane Delaisse, bonjour.
Bonjour, bonjour Guillaume.
Est-ce que tu peux te présenter pour nos auditeurs qui ne te connaissent sans doute pas ?
Et donc, ben oui, je m'appelle Morgane, j'ai 34 ans. J'ai vécu en Chine de 2009 à 2014, donc pendant cinq ans.
Et en rentrant, j'ai écrit un livre qui s'appelle Vivre la Chine, puisque j'ai eu la chance d'être journaliste sur place et d'écrire plusieurs guides déjà quand j'étais là-bas, quand j'habitais à Shanghai.
Tu l'as pas dit, mais tu es journaliste belge expatriée.
Tout à fait.
Tu vis aujourd'hui en France, je pense, c'est juste ?
C'est juste, c'est juste. Ouais, j'ai bougé, mais beaucoup plus près de notre plat pays.
Tu disais, tu étais journaliste en Chine, donc tu travaillais pour quelle publication ?
Voilà. Alors en fait, j'ai eu la chance quand je suis arrivée en 2009, en juillet 2009, de commencer par un stage dans un journal qui s'appelle Le Petit Journal, qui est en fait un site internet—
D'accord.
...pour tous les Français qui vivent à l'étranger. C'est un journal pour expatriés et y a dans chaque ville du monde, je pense qu'y a une trentaine ou une quarantaine d'éditions, une édition dédiée aux expatriés de cette ville.
En Chine, y a une édition à Pékin, à Shanghai et y a une édition à Hong Kong également. Et en fait, quand je suis arrivée, ben j'ai eu la chance de rencontrer le responsable de l'édition de Shanghai qui cherchait une stagiaire.
Puis moi, comme je sortais de mon master en communication à l'ULB, je me suis dit : « Ben c'est top, c'est exactement ça que j'ai envie de faire.
Ça va être l'occasion pour moi d'avoir une expérience professionnelle qui correspond à ce que je cherche », ce qui était une grande chance en arrivant en Chine un peu les mains dans les poches.
Et en plus qui allait me permettre de très vite découvrir et apprendre beaucoup de choses et sur la culture et sur l'histoire et sur la Chine en général quoi.
Donc ça, ça conciliait vraiment le fait d'avoir un boulot qui correspondait à mes études à l'autre bout du monde et en plus de pouvoir apprendre très vite beaucoup de choses sur le pays et sur la ville.
Alors, on va évidemment revenir plus tard sur la notion de, 'fin sur ce que c'est d'être journaliste en Chine, puisqu'on sait que c'est assez particulier, la presse là-bas.
Mmm-hmm.
Juste avant ça, donc tu vivais en Chine à partir de 2009, c'est juste ?
Oui, c'est ça. En juillet 2009, j'ai eu mon diplôme et quelques jours après, je suis partie. Et—
Et tu restais là-bas combien de temps ?
Cinq ans. Je suis restée cinq ans jusqu'en 2014. Je suis rentrée à peu près en mai 2014, pour mes 30 ans. Et—
OK. Et qu'est-ce qui t'avait amenée là-bas à la base ? Donc tu disais, c'est juste après que tu étais diplômée de l'ULB ?
C'est ça. En fait, j'avais fait un premier voyage en 2005, ensuite un deuxième voyage en 2008.
Et ben, ouais, quand j'étais partie déjà ces deux premières fois, j'avais eu la chance de faire des longs voyages, de rester un mois, un mois et demi à chaque fois.
Ben j'étais attirée de manière un peu inexplicable par la Chine. J'avais ce fantasme, hein, je pense que certaines personnes ont par rapport à l'Extrême-Orient, qui semblait mystérieux.
C'est un peu rigolo quand je le dis maintenant, mais c'est vrai que c'est l'image que j'en avais à l'époque. Voilà, un petit peu, ouais, mystérieux, plein de fantasmes.
Et du coup, quand j'y étais en vacances, j'ai vraiment eu, pas ce déclic, mais cette envie : « Ben un jour, je viendrai vivre ici.
Je ferai partie de cette foule immense et je vais me mêler à cette vie ici », quoi. En 2009, mon ex-copain est parti vivre en Chine.
Donc lui, il est Belge d'origine chinoise. Il a ses parents qui sont Shanghaïens. Et donc il avait eu cette envie de retourner un peu aux sources, d'aller travailler là-bas.
Et effectivement, on a eu cette envie de partir ensemble. Donc je l'ai rejoint. En fait, il est parti quelques mois avant moi et moi, en juillet, dès que j'ai eu mon diplôme, je l'ai rejoint.
Donc c'était un projet ensemble.
Oui, mais donc c'est très intéressant ce que tu dis sur, voilà, cet aspect mystérieux, exotique de l'Extrême-Orient et de la Chine de manière générale.
C'est parce que c'est complètement en fait ce qui nous amène à en parler aujourd'hui. C'est parce que je pense que pour la plupart des gens qui nous écoutent aujourd'hui, 'fin, je suppose
qu'ils sont un peu dans le même cas que moi, c'est-à-dire, ben on entend beaucoup parler de la Chine, évidemment, puisque c'est
plus d'un milliard d'habitants, mais ça reste assez mystérieux et on ne comprend pas tout et c'est quand même très différent.
Donc c'est, voilà, c'est complètement dans ce contexte-là qu'on fait ce podcast aujourd'hui.
Alors donc, on l'a dit, tu as publié un livre qui s'appelle Vivre la Chine chez Higari Editions et qui est donc finalement un guide pour les expatriés qui veulent s'installer en Chine.
Et dedans, tu dresses un peu le portrait de la Chine, de sa culture, son histoire, sa géographie, son fonctionnement.
Et aussi, tu donnes plein d'astuces pratico-pratiques sur le, 'fin voilà, comment, c'que c'est de vivre, bah littéralement, vivre la Chine, quand on est expatrié.
Alors, on va un peu dresser un portrait de la Chine pour essayer de mieux comprendre cette culture, voilà, qu'on disait assez mystérieuse.
Donc pour ça, on va commencer par dresser un petit peu le portrait de, 'fin traverser un peu l'histoire de la Chine.
Puisque ce que tu expliques dans le livre, c'est que c'est une très vieille civilisation de plus de 5 000 ans.
Oui.
C'qui est évidemment colossal. Voilà, notre petite Belgique à nous, elle a, que j'fasse vite quelques maths, elle a 180 ans, c'est ça ?
Ah, me demande pas de faire des maths, Guillaume.
190. Oui, 190 du coup, puisque c'est 1830. À l'échelle d'une vie, ça paraît énorme, mais en fait quand on compare à une civilisation comme la Chine, c'est absolument ridicule.
Et donc ce que tu expliques, c'est qu'il y a eu entre -1050 et -221,
ce qu'on appelle les Zhou. Donc c'est, si j'ai bien compris, une forme de royaume au sein de la Chine et que ils installent très rapidement un système
de dynastie, d'empereurs, avec tout au-dessus le souverain, l'empereur, et puis en dessous les seigneurs très fidèles au souverain.
Et puis encore en dessous, beh, le peuple, les agriculteurs qui ne valent finalement pas grand-chose. C'est juste ?
C'est tout à fait juste. Bah, c'est un peu un système qu'on retrouvera des siècles plus tard en Europe, un système féodal, mais qui a été créé, ouais, dès l'Antiquité en Chine, en fait. Tout à fait.
Mmm-hmm. Et donc ce système avec cet empereur chinois va durer jusqu'au début du 20e siècle. Donc ça fait, ouais, à peu près 3 000 ans.
Quelque chose d'assez récurrent à travers l'histoire de la Chine, ce sont les guerres entre les sept grands royaumes.
Ouais.
Donc ils sont morcelés, puis unifiés, puis morcelés de nouveau, et puis des dynasties qui se succèdent avec—
Bah en fait, le parallèle que j'aime bien faire, c'est, beh, voilà, que ça se rapproche aussi de l'histoire européenne avec les conquêtes entre les différents pays.
Sauf que c'est vraiment réduit à une région qui est aujourd'hui un seul pays, quoi. L'Europe s'est quand même morcelée en plein de pays.
La Chine, c'est resté— alors c'était sept royaumes à la base, effectivement, mais ce sont toujours restés à peu près la même zone géographique, avec des découpements qui peuvent varier en fonction des époques, effectivement.
Mais voilà, c'est le même jeu de guerre et de conquête des territoires, ce genre de choses. Mais aujourd'hui, c'est resté un pays unifié, quoi, contrairement à l'Europe qui est morcelée en plein de pays.
Voilà, c'est un peu le parallèle que je fais, quoi.
Et donc si on avance jusqu'au 19e siècle, à ce moment-là, y a eu des gros retards, tu expliques, en termes de conditions de vie, en termes d'hygiène,
qu'à côté de ça, l'Europe connaissait sa révolution industrielle, et que, bah de plus en plus, le gouvernement qui est donc, voilà, l'
empereur de Chine—
Mmm-hmm.
...le gouvernement semblait de plus en plus inadapté, inefficace.
Oui, en fait, c'est tout le système politique qui était complètement obsolète. En fait, l'empereur en Chine, il se voyait comme le Fils du Ciel.
J'vais pas dire le Fils de Dieu parce que c'était pas une religion, mais il se voyait comme le Fils du Ciel et toutes les décisions étaient totalement imposées aux ministres et après à l'ensemble de la population.
Avec cette idée assez caractéristique que ni les étrangers ni la modernité n'avaient leur place, en fait, en Chine.
Sauf que bon, le peuple vivait dans la misère, avait un retard effectivement au niveau des conditions de vie qui était incroyable.
L'espérance de vie était moitié réduite par rapport à celle qu'elle était en Europe à ce moment-là. Donc ce système politique, au 19e siècle, il avait plus de raison d'être du tout.
Et donc le refus de la Chine de faire commerce avec l'étranger, ça a mené à ce qu'on appelle les guerres de l'opium—
Ouais.
...entre 1839 et 1842. Et donc, évidemment, ils vont perdre puisque l'Europe était toute-puissante.
Et donc Hong Kong, et ça, on va revenir dessus, la situation très particulière de Hong Kong, devient à ce moment-là britannique.
Oui.
Et y a des concessions qui sont faites, bah voilà, à la France, aux USA, au Royaume-Uni, dans tous les grands ports chinois pour, beh voilà, autoriser de force le commerce avec ces pays-là.
Et donc tu expliques que les Chinois qui y vivent n'ont plus aucun droit et qu'ils se révoltent alors contre leur empereur par frustration.
Et oui, forcément, faut savoir, par exemple, à Shanghai, y avait plusieurs concessions. Y avait une concession française, une concession britannique et une concession internationale.
À l'entrée de la concession française, y avait un panneau, il était écrit : « Interdit aux chiens et aux Chinois ».
Ah oui, d'accord, ouais.
Donc voilà, ça place quand même la population plus bas que terre.
Mmm-hmm.
Forcément, les Chinois, au-delà
d'une haine assez compréhensible qu'ils vont développer pour les étrangers,
ils vont aussi se rebeller envers le système politique qui a, pas qui a laissé faire, mais qui a permis, qui a perdu, en tout cas, qui a perdu la guerre et qui a permis que
cette situation existe.
Ouais. Et donc y a une grande frustration, y a de nombreuses révoltes qui vont suivre au cours des décennies.
Voilà.
La plupart de ces révoltes vont être matées, mais en 1911, t'expliques que les élites intellectuelles chinoises décident qu'il faut une république.
Ouais.
Cette forme de monarchie. Et—
Mmh mmh.
...et l'empereur, à ce moment-là, avait cinq ans.
Ouais.
Ça, c'est très amusant. Il s'appelle Henry Puyi.
Puyi, ouais.
Et donc à ce moment-là, il est obligé d'abdiquer.
Oui, ben c'est le film Le dernier empereur de Chine, hein, qui raconte assez bien cette histoire-là. Effectivement, y avait une impératrice douairière au pouvoir pendant des années, pendant 60 ans, c'était Cixi.
Quand elle est décédée, elle a légué le pouvoir à un enfant qui avait trois ans, et qui est resté jusqu'à ses cinq ans.
Donc autant dire que c'était une marionnette—
Mmh mmh.
...dont les fils étaient tirés par on sait pas très bien qui. Y avait vraiment un terreau fertile à ce que le peuple se révolte.
Et c'est ce qui a mené effectivement à la naissance du Parti nationaliste qui en 1912, je crois, a pris le pouvoir et a créé la République de Chine. Oui, tout à fait.
Mmh. Ouais, donc Parti nationaliste à ce moment-là. Et puis quelques années après, l'arrivée du fameux Parti communiste.
Ce Parti communiste, il arrive dans quel contexte ? Pour quelles raisons ?
Bah en fait, si tu veux, le Parti nationaliste n'a pas pu résister à l'invasion japonaise.
D'accord, OK.
Et ça a été le terreau fertile pour le Parti communiste chinois se détacher du Parti nationaliste et tomber plutôt dans l'opposition.
Mmh mmh.
Et cette position dans l'opposition a permis d'aller faire un peu le tour dans les campagnes, d'aller voir ce qui se passait chez les gens et de rencontrer les populations les plus défavorisées, les plus reculées,
euh, bah essentiellement des paysans, hein, des ouvriers aussi.
Et c'est ce qui a créé, et alors donc c'est en 1934, la Longue Marche. Donc pendant un an, Mao Zedong va créer l'Armée rouge et il va rassembler au fur et à mesure des campagnes
qu'il croise sur son chemin quoi, qu'il va visiter, toute une armée de plus en plus massive de gens qui vont le suivre dans son projet.
Ensemble, ils vont parcourir plus de 10 000 kilomètres à travers la Chine. Et c'est comme ça que lui va monter son projet de Parti communiste.
Et entre-temps, l'invasion—
L'invasion ratée de Pékin par les Japonais ?
Voilà, c'est ça. Et du coup, ben c'était la guerre civile quoi, parce que si tu veux, tout le monde essayait un peu de prendre sa place à Pékin.
T'avais les nationalistes qui revendiquaient leur droit d'être là puisque c'était eux qui avaient pris le pouvoir.
T'avais les Japonais qui essayaient toujours d'envahir Pékin et les communistes qui se sentaient de plus en plus légitimes dans leur revendication de prendre le pouvoir quoi.
Ouais, donc guerre civile entre les nationalistes, les communistes. Voilà, cette invasion qui se solde par un échec de Pékin par les Japonais.
Et puis fin de la Deuxième Guerre mondiale, les Japonais sont en échec et donc l'invasion s'arrête complètement. Et Mao Zedong va monter au pouvoir en 1948 sans aucune résistance, puisque voilà, les Japonais sont partis. Et—
Voilà.
...il va proclamer ce qui est toujours en place aujourd'hui, hein, c'est la République populaire de Chine.
Oui, sur la place Tiananmen, tout à fait.
Et à ce moment-là, son adversaire politique Chiang Kai-shek, j'espère que je prononce bien.
Oui.
Se réfugie donc à Taïwan. Et tous les étrangers dont on parlait tout à l'heure sont sommés de repartir chez eux à ce moment-là.
À ce moment-là, la Chine, en 1949, devient un pays complètement fermé. Y a plus d'ambassade, il y a plus d'étrangers.
Les Chinois restent complètement entre eux pendant des années et ça va être même difficile d'envoyer, ben, on le sait hein, des journalistes, etc.
pour savoir ce qui se passe. Ça va être vraiment un pays totalement fermé sur lui-même pendant encore quelques décennies.
Et alors, ce dont on entend beaucoup parler, c'est la fameuse politique de répression de Mao Zedong, puisque donc—
Mmh mmh.
...tu expliques dans ton livre qu'à travers toutes ces décennies, y a 400 000 personnes qui sont envoyées dans des camps de rééducation.
Oui.
300 000 cadres du parti qui sont éliminés, que Mao réfute toute critique, qu'il mène une campagne contre tous ceux qui s'opposent à la construction de la Chine socialiste.
Tu parles aussi de, à la fin des années 50, ce qui s'appelle la politique du Grand Bond en avant. Est-ce que tu peux nous expliquer ce que c'est ?
Ben en fait, il a mis en place des politiques agricoles et industrielles qui se sont révélées un véritable fiasco.
Il était pas du tout en phase avec les besoins de la Chine de l'époque
et sous couvert de propulser le pays vers le futur, en tout cas de le tourner vers le futur et de le moderniser, il va mener des politiques désastreuses.
On sait pas exactement combien de personnes en sont les victimes. On estime qu'il y a eu entre 15 et 30 millions de morts dans les années 50 quoi.
Parce que… mais…
Ouais.
…pas qui ont été directement assassinés par le pouvoir évidemment, hein…
…mais…
Par famine.
…qui meurent de famine. Voilà, exactement.
Ouais. Ouais, OK. Et donc, ouais, et ça continue comme ça pendant encore quelques décennies. 1 million de cadres épurés entre 1962 et 1965.
Ça s'élargit aux bureaucrates, aux professeurs, aux bourgeois et à tous les, même tous les opposants supposés. Donc c'est assez violent.
Et puis tout change un peu après la mort de Mao en 1976.
Ouais.
Puisqu'à ce moment-là, la Chine va commencer à signer des accords internationaux avec notamment les USA. Et c'est finalement à ce moment-là le début de ce paradoxe chinois qui est,
voilà, c'est une Chine communiste, mais qui adopte quand même le modèle du capitalisme avec ce qu'ils appellent une économie socialiste de marché.
Oui, ça, c'est un terme inventé par Deng Xiaoping, qui est vu aujourd'hui quand même comme le père de la Chine moderne, mais qui a bien vu, hein, en 1979, que le modèle communiste avait ses limites.
Surtout, il voyait ce qui se passait ailleurs dans le monde. La fin des années 70, les années 80, c'était un peu un âge d'or pour les États-Unis, pour l'Europe qui réussissait très bien.
Le capitalisme à l'époque avait l'air de,
de répondre aux promesses, enfin, tenait ses promesses. Et donc, je pense qu'il s'est dit : « C'est maintenant ou jamais », parce que sinon la Chine va jamais prendre le monde en marche quoi.
La théorie qui revient souvent, c'est de se demander : « OK, la Chine est communiste, mais
comme elle adopte des accords internationaux, comme le commerce est possible, comme c'est finalement une forme de capitalisme, eh bien tout finira par suivre.
La démocratie finira par suivre, la liberté d'expression finira par suivre, la censure va s'arrêter. » Et en fait, aujourd'hui, on constate que c'est pas tellement le cas.
Non, pas du tout. Non, mais en fait, c'est effectivement un pays qui est ouvert à l'étranger et qui peut donner une sensation de fonctionner avec un système capitaliste.
Sauf que beaucoup d'entreprises sont nationales, sont dirigées par l'État et que le PCC a quand même tout le pouvoir politique.
Y a pas d'autre parti, y a pas d'opposition. Tout est à la botte du Parti communiste chinois. La démocratie, si elle
peut s'exprimer, notamment via les réseaux sociaux, y a quand même une très grosse censure, ce qui fait que ça reste très underground quoi, je vais le dire comme ça en mauvais français.
Donc y a des dissidents qui se parlent entre eux, mais en fait, le reste du monde ne les connaît pas.
Et puis y a pas d'élection, donc la démocratie n'existe pas. Les médias sont tous à la botte du PCC aussi.
Y a pas de, voilà. Enfin on est quand même encore très très loin de ce développement démocratique, qui… mais qui n'a jamais été promis par le Parti communiste, hein, ceci dit.
Ils n'ont jamais fait cette promesse-là. C'est le monde qui a eu ce fantasme…
Ce fantasme. Ouais, ouais, c'est ça. Ouais, ouais, ouais. Et alors, c'est aussi un petit peu dans ce contexte-là qu'y a cette fameuse image que tout le monde a vue du Tank Man de la place Tiananmen.
Mh.
C'est aussi dans un contexte de soif de démocratie, une soif de liberté d'expression.
Ouais.
Est-ce que tu peux nous expliquer un petit peu cette photo que tout le monde a vue et que… enfin tout le monde ne connaît pas forcément son histoire ?
Ben donc c'est l'histoire des étudiants qui se retrouvent spontanément sur la place Tiananmen, je pense que c'est avril ou mai 1989, avec un désir effectivement de démocratie, un vent de liberté et une soif d'ouverture.
Et ben malheureusement, ils vont complètement se faire massacrer. Ces protestations vont être complètement matées par les militaires.
On ne sait pas ce qui s'est passé sur la place Tiananmen le 4 juin 1989.
Mh.
Donc en fait cette photo…
Enfin toutes les infos sont censurées, les chiffres sont inconnus, ouais.
C'est inconnu. Personne ne sait exactement ce qui s'est passé. Donc ce Tank Man, c'est un étudiant qui est là debout face à quatre tanks qui veulent rentrer sur la place.
Et lui seul, avec… cette photo me bouleverse à chaque fois, avec son sac plastique dans la main droite…
Mh.
…qui essaye de résister seul face à quatre tanks quoi. Et on ne sait pas ce qui est arrivé à ce monsieur.
Probablement, il n'a pas eu un destin très heureux. Et bon, on estime qu'il y a eu des milliers de morts, hein, de tous les étudiants qui étaient sur la place Tiananmen à l'époque.
Mais ceux qui y étaient et qui sont encore vivants ont été fortement encouragés à se taire. Et puis sinon, ben voilà.
Mh. Ouais. Et donc
ça, c'était donc, on disait en 1989. Et alors, voilà, on s'approche tout doucement de l'époque actuelle, mais donc dans les années 90, ce qui s'est passé, c'est que,
la Chine s'est encore plus ouverte aux investissements étrangers, au commerce international.
Y a une reprise des relations avec Taïwan et la rétrocession de Hong Kong en 1997. Est-ce que tu peux nous parler un petit peu de Taïwan, de Hong Kong ?
Parce qu'on en parle régulièrement. C'est visiblement des territoires assez particuliers. Est-ce que Taïwan et Hong Kong sont chinois ou non ?
Ouh là, ça, c'est une polémique. Ça, c'est…
Ça dépend à qui tu demandes en fait.
Voilà, ça dépend à qui on demande. Demande à un Hongkongais s'il fait partie de la Chine continentale, il va te dire que non.
Demande à un cadre du parti de Pékin si Hong Kong fait partie de la Chine, il va te dire que oui.
Moi, ce que je peux en dire, en tout cas d'un point de vue totalement extérieur et presque un peu futile, c'est que quand on habite en Chine, moi, j'habitais à Shanghai, quand j'allais à Hong Kong j'avais plus le sentiment d'être en Chine.
J'étais dans un autre pays. Y a beaucoup, beaucoup de choses.
Ça se sentait comment ?
Ça se sent par, alors, par des bêtises hein, mais par le fait que les voitures roulent à gauche.
D'accord.
Les bus, ce sont des bus impériaux comme on voit à Londres, les trams aussi. Ça se marque par le fait que les gens font la file dans le métro.
Y a pas de bousculade.
D'accord.
Les gens sont très respectueux des feux de signalisation. Y a une ambiance… 'fin, ça, c'est vraiment un cadre extérieur.
Alors voilà, ça semble très futile, hein, dit comme ça, mais on sent qu'on n'est pas en Chine continentale. C'est pas le même pays.
On sent un petit peu l'influence de l'Occident, finalement, puisque c'était autrefois une colonie britannique.
Oui, oui, bien sûr. Mais ça reste,
un paysage tout à fait asiatique avec les écritures. Ce qu'il faut savoir aussi, par exemple à Hong Kong comme à Taïwan d'ailleurs, c'est que les caractères chinois sont ce qu'on appelle les caractères traditionnels.
En fait, le Parti communiste, quand il est arrivé au pouvoir, il a changé tous les caractères chinois pour passer à un modèle simplifié.
Mais Hong Kong et Taïwan, qui n'ont pas été sous l'emprise du Parti communiste chinois à cette époque-là, ont gardé les caractères traditionnels.
Donc ce sont même pas les mêmes caractères. Moi qui ai un petit peu appris le chinois très modestement, ben voilà, je savais plus lire ce que j'avais appris puisque ce sont pas les mêmes caractères.
Alors, les Chinois peuvent, hein. Les Chinois savent lire les deux modèles. Mais voilà, on n'est pas dans le même pays, on sent que c'est pas la même histoire.
'Fin, tout ça semble très futile, mais voilà, c'est comme ça.
Oui, oui. Et du coup, la situation de Taïwan, en quoi est-ce qu'elle est différente ?
Alors, Taïwan, c'est un petit peu plus difficile pour moi de t'en parler. Je connais moins bien. Taïwan, c'est une île,
qui a été… 'fin, où tous les nationalistes, et dont Tchang Kaï-chek dont on parlait tout à l'heure, se sont rassemblés et ont déclaré leur indépendance.
Mais les Chinois n'ont jamais reconnu cette indépendance. Alors aujourd'hui, ben je sais que aux Jeux olympiques, ils ont leur propre drapeau et défilent à part,
mais par exemple, au niveau de l'ONU, etc., je sais pas trop si ils sont reconnus.
Donc je connais pas très bien la situation de Taïwan, c'est un peu spécial. En tout cas, ils sont vus comme les traîtres de la Chine continentale, ça, c'est sûr.
Et dans l'actualité récente, on a beaucoup parlé de Hong Kong. Est-ce que tu peux nous parler un peu de ce qui se passe en ce moment ?
Ben donc en fait, le début de la rétrocession de Hong Kong à la Chine a démarré à la fin des années 90. Donc en fait, les Britanniques avaient signé un accord acceptant de rendre la ville à la Chine.
Mais sauf qu'entre-temps, la ville, elle s'était développée tout à fait différemment. Ce que j'ai oublié quand même de mentionner, qui est hyper important, c'est que les médias sont libres, les réseaux sociaux sont libres.
En Chine continentale, on n'a pas accès à Facebook, on n'a pas accès à Twitter. Y a le grand pare-feu chinois qui bloque tout un tas de sites occidentaux et essentiellement des réseaux sociaux.
Quand on arrive à Hong Kong, on se connecte sur Facebook instantanément, on peut y accéder, y a aucun souci. Donc les Hongkongais, ils ont l'habitude de cette liberté, de cette démocratie.
Le système en place, y a des élections. 'Fin, c'est, voilà, c'est quand même une vie qui est totalement différente de ce que connaissent les Chinois.
Sauf que, ben les Britanniques avaient signé un accord de rétrocession qui est en train d'arriver à son terme et qui fait que Hong Kong doit, à terme, devenir totalement chinois.
Et je sais que notamment, les autorités de Pékin ont voulu voter une loi pour le rapatriement des dissidents chinois qui sont à Hong Kong pour les ramener dans les prisons chinoises.
Et voilà, ça a créé un tollé. La révolution de Hong Kong, elle a commencé y a quelques années. On en parle beaucoup ces derniers mois, mais y a eu la révolution des parapluies, qui doit avoir cinq, six ans.
Les Hongkongais sont très attachés à leur liberté, à leur démocratie. Malheureusement, les autorités hongkongaises, elles ont pas vraiment la force de s'opposer aux décisions de Pékin.
Donc c'est en train aussi d'être maté par les militaires. 'Fin, ça se passe très mal. J'ai très peur, moi, pour ce qui va se passer là-bas.
Je vois pas une issue très heureuse, malheureusement. D'autant que, ben la communauté internationale se mouille pas beaucoup, hein.
Mh. Et donc là, on parle de la politique, donc du Parti communiste chinois. Quand on parle aux Chinois eux-mêmes, aux Chinois de Chine et qu'on leur parle de Hong Kong, quelle est leur réaction ?
Alors moi, ce que je dois d'abord dire, c'est qu'en tant qu'étranger, c'est très délicat de parler de politique avec les Chinois.
Pour plusieurs raisons. D'abord, ils vont pas trop apprécier qu'on ait l'air de mieux connaître le pays qu'eux. C'est assez légitime, hein, personne n'a envie de se faire donner une leçon sur son propre pays par un étranger.
D'un autre côté, nous, étrangers, on a une vision, on pense que, ben voilà, qu'ils ont été endoctrinés par la propagande et que donc ils ne connaissent rien.
En fait, ils en savent beaucoup plus que ce qu'ils acceptent de dire à un étranger. Mais ils ont cette espèce de retenue, de fierté qui fait que, en fait,
à moins d'être vraiment très proche, très intime, c'est difficile de poser ce genre de questions et de savoir : qu'est-ce que tu penses de Hong Kong ?
C'est très délicat de demander ça, de demander : « Qu'est-ce que tu penses du Parti communiste chinois ?
Qu'est-ce que tu penses de Hong Kong ? » Ça va le placer dans une situation très inconfortable pour lui. S'il dit du mal, il va avoir le sentiment de critiquer son pays, ce qu'un Chinois globalement ne ferait pas.
Toute généralisation a des contre-exemples hein, mais voilà, c'est ça. Et ou alors, on va dans la confrontation, on peut aller un peu cash avec des gens qu'on connaît moins bien, par exemple.
Ça peut déjà arriver.
C'est un peu plus facile. Ça m'est déjà arrivé, mais on va avoir une réponse très formatée. Bah Hong Kong, c'est chinois, point, point barre.
Ouais.
Et ça ne souffre pas de discussion. Donc c'est pas intéressant, en fait, finalement.
La position d'étranger doit forcément nous amener en Chine à beaucoup d'humilité vis-à-vis des questions politiques.
Aussi parce qu'ils voient que le système chez nous, malgré tout ce qu'on en dit, est perfectible et ils en tirent aussi des conclusions.
Ils disent : « Oui, mais vous nous parlez de démocratie à tout prix, mais ça a pas l'air d'aussi bien fonctionner que ça pour vous.
Vous êtes tout le temps en grève, en révolte. » Enfin bon. Donc c'est…
On parle de la France à ce moment-là.
Ouais, ouais, bah la France est beaucoup plus connue que la Belgique hein, en Chine, évidemment. Donc, ils connaissent certainement mieux la France que la Belgique, mais c'est un peu délicat, ouais.
C'est un peu délicat de parler de… il faut vraiment être très intime. Alors moi, j'ai eu la chance d'avoir de très bons amis avec qui on a pu avoir des discussions plus ou moins libres.
Et mais voilà, oui, forcément, ils reconnaissent qu'un pays qui a été libre ne veut pas revenir à un système qui l'est moins.
Voilà, mais ils vont pas aller beaucoup plus loin dans leurs discours.
C'est ça, ouais. Et donc, de manière générale, savoir ce que les Chinois pensent de Mao aujourd'hui, savoir ce qu'ils pensent du 4 juin, et cetera, toutes ces choses-là, c'est trop touchy pour en discuter.
Donc c'est difficile d'avoir une idée ?
Ouais, c'est difficile, à moins de savoir très bien lire le chinois, ce qui n'était pas mon cas, et d'aller sur les réseaux sociaux chinois.
Et là, on peut lire des choses très intéressantes, très pointues, très impertinentes.
C'est pas censuré, justement, les réseaux chinois ?
Bah en fait, les dissidents, ils jouent un peu un jeu de chat et de la souris, en contournant les mots censurés.
Donc la censure fonctionne sur un principe de mots clés. Donc tape 4 juin dans un Google chinois, c'est sûr que t'auras absolument aucune réponse.
Donc les internautes chinois, ils ont détourné ça. Quand ils parlent du 4 juin, toute une époque, ils disaient le 35 mai.
D'accord, ouais.
Ça, le temps que les censeurs captent de quoi on parlait, bah ils ont pu commémorer, se souvenir. Et donc, à moins de parler très bien chinois, c'est difficile de savoir exactement ce qu'ils pensent de la politique.
Ce qui n'empêche pas qu'effectivement, y a des choses très intéressantes qui se passent, mais il faut avoir la chance de bien lire le chinois.
Mais les gens sont beaucoup plus cultivés qu'on ne le pense. Enfin, ils réfléchissent beaucoup plus loin. Ils sont pas du tout endoctrinés comme,
comme on peut le croire quand on arrive et qu'on allume la télé et qu'on voit que c'est quasiment Parti communiste TV sur toutes les chaînes quoi.
Et donc y a une certaine émancipation, y a une certaine réflexion, une certaine critique, voilà, chez ces réseaux dissidents.
Mh mh.
Est-ce que tu dirais que c'est généralisé, qu'y a ça dans la population globale ou bien est-ce que justement, cette population chinoise est bah plutôt, voilà, on marche sur les rails, on colorie sans dépasser ?
Ah, c'est difficile à dire parce qu'ils ont quand même… y a déjà un problème de génération. Y a déjà des différences de génération.
Tu as la génération qui a connu Mao Zedong et la répression, la rééducation des élites, où tout le monde se méfiait de son voisin, globalement.
En Chine, y a encore beaucoup de personnes âgées qui laissent leur porte ouverte. La porte de la rue hein, la porte de la maison qui donne sur la rue à l'extérieur, parce qu'ils viennent d'une époque où on voulait surtout ne rien cacher quoi.
Et donc, y a certainement dans cette génération-là des dissidents, mais ils sont beaucoup trop méfiants que pour émettre une quelconque opinion en dehors de cercles très très très restreints.
Après, parmi la jeune génération, j'ai l'espoir que c'est plus généralisé, qu'entre eux, ils ont des débats passionnés.
Évidemment, ce qu'il faut aussi voir, c'est que la Chine aujourd'hui a fait énormément de progrès. Le bien-être et les conditions de vie se sont vraiment énormément améliorées ces dernières années.
Et y a aussi une forme de reconnaissance vis-à-vis du pouvoir, de se dire : « Bah c'est aussi grâce à eux qu'on vit bien aujourd'hui et qu'on est reconnu sur la scène internationale et qu'on est devenu une puissance.
» Donc y a plusieurs sentiments qui sont partagés. Certes, c'est pas parfait, mais quand même, c'est pas si mal.
Donc voilà, c'est nuancé.
Ce que tu expliques aussi dans le livre, c'est que tu parles des différents groupes ethniques qui vivent en Chine.
Mh mh.
Donc tu expliques qu'il y a une ethnie qui est majoritaire qui est l'ethnie han.
Ouais.
92 % de la population et que
elle partage, alors ça, je serais très curieux d'en savoir plus. Tu expliques que tous ces Chinois partagent une philosophie et un art de vivre commun, mais qu'au-delà de ça, ils diffèrent en termes de
d'ethnicité, de religion, de, voilà, 'fin, de culture, même de langue, puisque y a plusieurs…
Mmh-mmh.
…plusieurs dialectes en Chine.
Ouais.
Et donc qu'est-ce que c'est que cette philosophie et cet art de vivre commun qui réunit 92 % de Chinois qui ne parlent pas la même langue ?
Alors en fait, les Hans, les 92 % de Hans, ils parlent tous la même langue, hein, ils parlent le mandarin.
Ah OK, autant pour moi.
Les autres ethnies ont des langues et des écritures différentes. Mais par contre, 100 % des Chinois,
partagent effectivement des valeurs communes qui sont transmises à l'école nationale, puisqu'à l'école, on n'enseigne que le chinois mandarin.
En tout cas, en premier lieu. Les ethnies peuvent éventuellement avoir des cours dans leur langue, mais ce sera une langue secondaire, comme nous, on apprendrait le néerlandais ou l'anglais plus tard quoi.
Donc, ils partagent quand même un enseignement qui est validé par le Parti communiste-
Mmh
...qui tend un peu à lisser les disparités religieuses, ethniques, et cetera. Ouais, ouais.
Ouais. Et qu'est-ce qui diffère à ce moment-là ? 'Fin, quelle est la différence entre un Chinois qui est Han et un Chinois qui est d'une autre minorité ethnique ?
Ben, tu as des minorités qui sont musulmanes, tu as des-
Ouais, les Ouïghours, ouais
...Ouais, par exemple, oui. Tu as des minorités qui sont mongoles, qui vivent-
Mmh
...encore de manière nomade. Tu as des gens qui sont tibétains. Donc y a beaucoup de choses qui peuvent différer, que ce soit la langue, que ce soit la religion, que ce soit les traditions, les coutumes.
Ça peut se voir dans les vêtements qu'ils portent, ça peut se voir dans-
D'accord, OK
...l'architecture de leurs villages. 'Fin y a plein de choses très différentes qui peuvent se manifester.
Et donc, t'expliques aussi que les minorités ont des avantages particuliers par rapport aux Hans, puisque les minorités peuvent avoir deux enfants et ils ont des garanties d'admission dans les écoles.
Ouais. Alors aujourd'hui, la politique de l'enfant unique, elle touche à sa fin en Chine hein, puisque même les Hans peuvent avoir deux enfants dans certaines conditions qui sont quasiment tout le temps réunies.
C'est que les deux parents doivent être enfants uniques chacun.
D'accord, OK.
Et alors, ils peuvent avoir deux enfants. Mais dans les faits, énormément de gens sont enfants uniques aujourd'hui. Donc-
Mmh-mmh
...beaucoup de gens peuvent avoir deux enfants. Et puis, ben les minorités, effectivement, on leur a accordé certains droits, pour pas que les ethnies s'éteignent.
Maintenant, voilà, il faut que quand même leur différence soit, comme je te disais, lissée, pas qu'ils revendiquent trop d'indépendance quoi.
Ouais, ouais. Et donc, peut-être un mot alors sur le,
le cas très particulier des Ouïghours. Je sais pas si t'as suivi un petit peu l'actualité récente, mais donc, ben, on parle de, voilà, d'extermination, de camps de concentration,
du gouvernement qui va récolter des organes chez des Ouïghours.
Mais qu'est-ce qui se passe en fait ? 'Fin qu'est-ce que c'est que ces horreurs ?
Ben là, pour le coup, la propagande et la censure font très très très très bien leur travail. C'est très difficile de savoir ce qui se passe.
Les Ouïghours sont-- voilà, on en parle aujourd'hui, mais la question tibétaine, elle existe depuis des années. Ouais, c'est très difficile de savoir exactement ce qui se passe.
OK.
En tout cas, y a une répression très forte. Tous ceux qui revendiquent une indépendance vis-à-vis de Pékin sont très durement réprimés.
Et c'est-- ouais, c'est difficile de savoir ce qui se passe. Honnêtement, on pense qu'ils sont enfer-- 'fin que toute personne qui s'exprime est enfermée dans des camps de travail forcés.
Ce qui est le cas d'ailleurs de dissidents, quelle que soit leur ethnie hein. Y a les Ouïghours, y a les Tibétains, mais les dissidents Hans sont pas forcément mieux traités.
Ouais.
Ce qu'il y a, c'est que en plus, ils sont vus avec beaucoup de condescendance, les minorités ethniques.
Mais justement, c'est ça que je comprends pas. C'est que à la fois, on les autorise à se reproduire davantage, avoir deux enfants et en même temps, on les voit visiblement avec beaucoup de dédain et même un certain mépris.
Mmh-mmh.
Je comprends pas très bien pourquoi on les aime, 'fin on les aime assez pour leur dire : « Il faut que vous persistiez ».
Et en même temps, on les déteste.
Je pense qu'on leur donne un espace de liberté en espérant qu'ils vont moins se rebeller. Voilà, en se disant-
C'est ça, c'est
...on leur donne une petite part du gâteau, comme ça, ils vont nous laisser tranquilles. Je pense. Bon, de nouveau, ce sont quand même des questions politiques assez pointues.
Moi, je suis pas du tout spécialisée là-dedans. C'est ce que je comprends. Ce que je vois, c'est que dans une ville comme Shanghai, les minorités ethniques, elles sont pas-
'fin, tu vois rarement des cadres dans les grandes entreprises issues d'une minorité ethnique.
'Fin, elles sont quand même reléguées à des fonctions moins glorieuses. Et voilà, beaucoup de mendiants, de marchands dans la rue et tout, ils viennent plutôt de ces minorités-là quoi.
Mais alors, pour parler un petit peu des différences fondamentales culturelles entre, ben l'Europe au sens large et la Chine, on revient souvent avec cette idée, ce concept de yin et de yang.
Donc voilà, rien ne s'oppose, tout se complète.
Mmh-mmh.
Est-ce que tu peux nous parler un peu de comment est-ce que ça se constate, comment est-ce que ça s'observe au jour le jour en Chine ?
Parce que justement, ça m'a l'air d'être en opposition complète avec ce dont on vient de parler au niveau des minorités ethniques.
Ben ça se manifeste par, ben par le fait justement qu'on veut l'harmonie dans la société en essayant de faire le moins de vagues possible.
Je pense que c'est les
Le gros avantage du Parti communiste chinois, c'est effectivement qu'il dirige un peuple qui a une vision de la société qui recherche toujours l'harmonie et qui veut effectivement faire le moins de vagues possible.
Donc, on préférera la solution soft, si je peux dire, plutôt que la confrontation quoi. Moi, c'est comme ça que je le ressens.
Je sais qu'un Chinois, il va intégrer le concept de yin et de yang d'une manière plutôt personnelle en fait, notamment à travers la médecine chinoise, la médecine traditionnelle chinoise,
par ce, par les exercices qu'il fait, ce qu'il va manger, etc.
Il va toujours chercher un équilibre dans sa vie. Donc par exemple, la manière dont ils construisent les repas, y a des aliments yin et des aliments yang et il faut les manger de manière proportionnée.
Et si un repas, on mange un aliment yin, il faudra toujours le contrebalancer avec un aliment yang. Et toute la-- donc en fait, c'est plutôt un précepte
individuel pour moi que vraiment le-- basé sur, 'fin qui peut s'appliquer vraiment à la société quoi.
Pour moi, l'idée de la société chinoise, c'est en tout cas la recherche de l'harmonie et le yin et le yang. C'est, voilà, c'est une théorie qui recherche cette harmonie-là.
Mh. Et donc tu parles aussi du concept de garder la face. Est-ce que tu peux nous expliquer un petit peu ce que c'est ?
Alors, la face, c'est un concept un petit peu subtil hein, c'est pas juste une question de susceptibilité. C'est vraiment très important de ne pas faire perdre la face à un Chinois et de lui donner de la face.
Donc en fait, ça se traduit par de grandes marques de respect pour son interlocuteur chinois, beaucoup de modestie de notre part quoi en tant qu'étranger.
Et en fait, lui-même, il va répondre de la même façon. Il va lui-même être modeste, il va lui-même-- donc en fait, c'est un espèce de jeu,
un petit peu difficile à comprendre au début, de flatter les egos, de donner de la fierté, de jamais trop remettre en cause les décisions d'un patron, par exemple, de caresser un peu dans le sens du poil son interlocuteur.
Et si on n'est pas d'accord avec ce qu'il dit, de trouver un moyen plutôt détourné, de contourner le problème pour arriver à lui expliquer en fait.
Donc donner de la face, c'est, 'fin c'est vraiment très important, notamment dans les relations professionnelles. Ça, on peut pas faire de business avec un Chinois si on lui fait perdre la face, c'est foutu.
Et dans les relations personnelles, c'est aussi, voilà, c'est une marque de respect, on va dire, envers sa famille, ses proches, de dire : « Je reconnais la valeur que tu as, j'ai de la chance d'être ton ami
ou de faire partie de ta famille. »
Ouais, et donc il est en aucun cas toléré de s'énerver, de perdre ses moyens, de perdre son sang-froid. Et finalement, mettre la honte à quelqu'un, c'est le pire des crimes, si je comprends bien.
Exactement. En fait, globalement hein, pour moi, ce que je trouve le plus dépaysant, le plus surprenant en Chine, c'est les relations aux autres, c'est les règles de savoir-vivre.
Et donc, ben typiquement, pas de confrontation, pas d'énervement en société. Et ça peut parfois être un peu difficile parce qu'un Chinois a la réputation de ne jamais dire non.
Un Chinois qui se retrouve dans l'embarras, parce que bon ben voilà, pour X ou Y raison, ça peut quand même arriver d'être pris à défaut, il va plutôt se mettre à rire.
Le genre de situation qui, nous, pourrait nous énerver très vite et se dire : « Non, mais attends, non seulement il a tort, mais en plus, il se moque de moi », quoi.
Mais pour lui, c'est juste une façon de reconnaître que : « Ben ouais, j'ai eu tort, mais par contre, s'te plaît, me fais pas la honte de me faire dire que je me suis trompé », quoi.
Donc c'est, voilà, les relations aux autres sont assez difficiles. Et c'est vrai que même la face, même en ayant vécu cinq ans, j'ai un peu du mal encore à expliquer toutes les subtilités.
Mais effectivement, oui, toujours être dans la recherche de l'harmonie, de la société, des relations, arrondir les angles.
Et j'ai l'impression qu'il y a aussi une très grande importance donc de la notion de groupe. On appartient à un tout.
Et donc, finalement, si je mets, entre guillemets, si je mets la honte, entre guillemets, à un Chinois, si je lui fais perdre la face,
c'est pas juste lui, c'est son groupe, sa famille, la société pour laquelle il travaille, sa région, son pays.
Un milliard de personnes, ouais, tout à fait. Surtout en tant qu'étranger, si tu fais perdre la face à un Chinois, ben tu fais perdre la face à la Chine.
Donc c'est quand même une grosse responsabilité sur tes épaules hein.
Est-ce que ça t'est déjà arrivé à toi ?
Certainement. Certainement. En fait, je sais pas, j'ai pas d'exemple. Y a certainement des gestes hein, qui sont déplacés aussi que j'ai dû faire.
On se-- voilà, je l'ai appris à mes dépens, on se mouche pas à table. Ça, c'est le-
D'accord, ouais
...pire chose que tu puisses faire à une table de Chinois. Alors que dans la rue, quand moi j'y habitais, les gens crachaient encore.
Je pense que ça a disparu, mais euh...
Et donc au moment où tu te mouches à table, tu mets la honte à sa famille, sa culture, son pays et toute la Chine entière.
Oui, et encore plus complexe, je perds la face moi-même et je fais perdre la face à tout mon groupe. Et pour eux, ils veulent pas assister à ça.
Ça les met très mal à l'aise, ça les met dans une position très mal à l'aise de me voir me faire perdre la face toute seule, en fait.
C'est un peu tordu, hein, à expliquer mais-
Oh, j'comprends, ouais
Tu vois ?
C'est finalement un rapport à la honte. On voudrait même pas que ça existe. 'Fin, cette idée de dire le déshonneur en tant que tel, que ce soit chez Morgane ou chez moi ou chez qui que ce soit-
Il ne doit pas exister
...c'est absolument horrible. C'est ça, ouais.
Exactement. Ouais, ouais.
OK.
Le déshonneur à aucun prix. Ouais, c'est-- mais ce qu'il faut accepter quand on vit en Chine, c'est qu'y a des choses qui resteront mystérieuses et insaisissables, hein.
Moi, j'y ai vécu cinq ans et y a des gens que je connais qui y vivent encore, ça fait 15 ans. Ils ont accepté qu'ils comprendraient jamais tout.
Et c'est la clé, hein.
Quand j'étais en Chine
avec mon ex-copain, on a décidé de se marier et on a voulu, comme lui était d'origine, est toujours d'ailleurs d'origine chinoise, on a voulu adopter un peu les traditions chinoises qui consistent à faire,
ben, de jolies photos avant la cérémonie.
On met de beaux costumes, on va se prendre en photo dans les parcs, devant les monuments. J'pense que ça se fait de plus en plus ici, en Belgique, en Europe, mais là-bas, c'est une institution.
Les photos de mariage, c'est vraiment une institution. Les femmes, elles mettent plusieurs robes pendant le shooting.
'Fin, c'est vraiment un truc assez important. Donc on avait décidé de le faire aussi. Et, ben pour l'occasion, tant qu'à aller dans la tradition chinoise, moi, j'avais décidé de mettre un qipao, une robe chinoise.
Et donc on est allés au cœur de la vieille ville de Shanghai.
On a fait pas mal de photos. Et là, j'ai vraiment vu dans le regard des gens, tous les Chinois qui étaient là, qui me regardaient, blonde aux yeux bleus, qui portait le qipao.
Ils étaient hyper fiers de se-- 'fin, ouais, de se dire : « Ben non seulement elle a adopté nos traditions, en plus, elle porte notre costume.
» J'ai vu que, ben là, je leur avais vraiment donné de la face et qu'ils avaient cette sensation que je donnais de la face à tout un peuple, à toute une histoire, à toute une civilisation.
C'était très émouvant, c'était très beau.
C'était différent de quand tu te mouchais à table.
Oui, ça a été mieux. Voilà, je me suis rattrapée. On va dire que j'ai rattrapé l'accident du mouchoir, exactement.
Et donc, mais donc c'est cette-- alors quoi, ce serait la contrepartie de cette notion de honte et de déshonneur, c'est, voilà, l'honneur que tu faisais à leur culture, à leur patrie.
On peut dire ça ?
Ouais, tout à fait. Ben, c'est pour ça que j'pense, par exemple, que c'est très important pour un étranger d'apprendre quelques mots de chinois.
Au-delà pour apprendre à communiquer, c'est quand même, voilà, c'est quand même essentiel quand on décide d'aller vivre dans un pays, d'apprendre la langue sur place.
Mais en Chine, ça prend une saveur particulière parce que j'pense que les gens le prennent comme un honneur quoi, de se dire : « Ah, il apprend, cet étranger qui vient de si loin, il apprend notre langue ».
Vraiment, effectivement, comme tu dis, il nous fait un grand honneur quoi.
Et est-ce que cette notion de-- qu'on évoquait y a un instant, le fait que on ne veut même pas entendre parler de la notion de déshonneur, ça les met très mal à l'aise.
Mmm-hmm.
Est-ce que c'est pas quelque chose qu'on peut mettre en lien avec, ben justement, la censure sur Internet et le fait que
la critique du gouvernement, la critique de l'ordre établi doit disparaître, doit être cachée, on cache ça sous le tapis, vite, hop, ça disparaît.
'Fin, j'pose la question : est-ce qu'on peut faire un lien entre les deux ?
En tout cas, le Parti communiste chinois, il doit l'expliquer de cette façon-là. Certainement.
OK, je ferai un bon communiste chinois.
Oui.
Tu expliquais qu'un Chinois, alors, ne va jamais te-- entrer dans la confrontation et te faire un déshonneur et te mettre mal à l'aise.
Mais, de dos, en douce, il peut essayer de te la faire à l'envers, si je comprends bien. 'Fin, si j'ai bien compris ce que tu disais dans ton livre.
Oui.
Et que typiquement, tu fais la file, ça se passe jamais très, très bien et que on essaie toujours de te piquer ta place.
Oui, oui, oui, oui. Non, non, mais c'est sûr que je dresse pas non plus un portrait aveuglément idyllique de la Chine.
Y a des choses très irritantes qui peuvent se passer. Au-delà de se faire piquer sa place, ce qui est quand même pas si courant, même si c'est arrivé, c'est la notion de distance personnelle qui est-
Ouais
...dans un pays d'un milliard d'habitants, différente
de ce qu'on connaît, nous, chez nous.
Donc, la notion de pudeur, comme j'te disais, moi, j'fais mes courses au supermarché ou au marché, ben on zieute sans aucun scrupule, sans aucune retenue dans mon caddie, mais ostensiblement, tu vois.
'Fin, c'est vraiment pas un petit coup d'œil discret quoi.
Oui, parce que c'est même pas perçu comme une faute.
Ah non, non, non, non, non, c'est pas-- voilà, j'te dis, le savoir-vivre, il se place tout à fait ailleurs.
Et, voilà.
Mais quand on fait une faute, quand on fait une faute, on le fait en douce dans ton dos.
Ouais.
Et on essaie de ne pas perdre-- 'fin-
Exactement
...parce que le but, c'est surtout de ne pas se faire repérer et on essaie de-
...de pas perdre la face, du coup.
Mmm-hmm. Parce qu'y a quand même plein d'histoires de... Alors moi, j'ai jamais eu de problèmes hein, mais y a quand même pas mal d'entrepreneurs étrangers qui se sont associés avec des Chinois et à qui on l'a mis à l'envers.
Voilà, ça, ça existe aussi, des problèmes de cet ordre-là. Bon, j'pense que ça existe partout après hein.
Donc est-ce que c'est propre à la Chine ? Ça m'étonnerait, mais c'est sûr que ouais, y a des problèmes de cet ordre-là.
Donc on disait il y a un instant qu'y avait très fort cette notion d'appartenance à un groupe. Et dans ton livre, tu évoques rapidement que ces dernières années, on voit apparaître une forme de...
'Fin, la montée d'une forme d'individualisme.
Oui.
Est-ce que c'est quelque chose qui se constate surtout chez les jeunes, j'imagine ?
Oui, c'est ça. C'est vraiment générationnel. Là, l'exemple qui me vient en tête, c'est par exemple les jeunes femmes qui revendiquent le droit au célibat. Chose...
Ah oui, d'accord.
...totalement impensable il y a encore quelques décennies. En Chine, la notion de famille, elle est encore très différente de chez nous.
Comme on l'a déjà évoqué, en tant qu'enfant, tu dois faire honneur à tes parents, tu dois faire honneur à ta famille, notamment à travers le mariage.
Si tu fais un bon mariage, bah non seulement... 'Fin, en fait, le but de faire un bon mariage, c'est de faire honneur à ses parents, hein.
Je te donne une vision un peu ancestrale, mais qui a perduré encore jusqu'à y a pas si longtemps, c'était le cas.
Aujourd'hui, les jeunes revendiquent le droit au célibat et c'est clairement une notion d'individualisme que les anciennes générations ne peuvent pas du tout comprendre et accepter.
Mh. Donc là, on est en rupture complète avec la notion de, voilà, garder la face puisqu'on... Bah oui, si c'est la pire insulte qu'on puisse faire à sa famille, à ses parents,
c'est que finalement, quoi, les jeunes s'en foutent de garder la face ou qu'est-ce que... ?
Non, c'est de l'individualisme comme tu disais. Ils aspirent à un bonheur un peu plus personnel et ils placent moins que leurs aînés le bonheur dans l'harmonie de la société.
Mh.
Bah je rapproche ça à sans doute notre vision occidentale du bonheur qui est avant tout personnelle et qui est moins basée sur l'harmonie d'un pays...
Ouais.
...d'une communauté. Je le vois comme ça. C'est le monde qui évolue. La Chine s'est ouverte au monde, elle évolue avec le monde, pour le meilleur et pour le pire.
Et bah voilà, pour les anciennes générations, ça passe par ça.
Tu parlais de, voilà, tu donnais l'exemple des jeunes femmes qui assument le choix du célibat, ce qui est en rupture complète avec les traditions.
Ça me fait penser, de manière générale, comment est-ce que tu décrirais la situation des femmes en Chine ?
Elle progresse. Pendant très longtemps, la femme n'avait pas d'état civil, n'avait pas de statut. On peut reconnaître au moins une chose au communisme, c'est qu'il a apporté un statut à la femme dans la société.
Maintenant, alors y a plusieurs choses. D'une part...
Ouais.
...pendant la politique de l'enfant unique, traditionnellement, les familles voulaient tous avoir un garçon.
Mh.
Parce que c'était ce qui apportait le plus d'honneur à la famille, c'était d'avoir un garçon. Ce qui fait qu'aujourd'hui, y a un gros déficit de femmes.
Je pense que dans certaines régions, et c'est notamment pour ça que la politique de l'enfant unique prend fin, y a 130 naissances de garçons pour 130 % naissances de filles.
Donc y a quand même un gros déficit de femmes. Donc tous les hommes, tous les parents qui ont voulu un garçon désespèrent aujourd'hui de trouver une femme à leur fils, quoi.
Donc ce qui a, par la force des choses, modifié le statut de la femme, qui a tout d'un coup plus de pouvoir, plus son mot à dire.
Après, dans les relations au sein de la famille, c'est un peu...
J'ai jamais été trop marquée, moi, par le fait que la femme était, aujourd'hui, en tout cas, avait un statut différent de ce qu'elle peut avoir chez nous en Europe, quoi.
C'est certainement perfectible, mais il est pas ce qu'il a été. C'est fini les pieds bandés, c'est fini les femmes reléguées à la cuisine.
Voilà, c'est pas mal.
Et est-ce que... Oui, 'fin tout dépend où...
C'était un peu approximatif comme réponse.
...tout dépend où on met la barre, mais...
Mais voilà...
Ouais, non, mais...
Effectivement, tout dépend où on met la barre. Je veux dire, si tu compares avec l'Europe où la situation est loin d'être idéale, mais où elle est loin d'être la pire, c'est à peu près identique. Voilà.
Ah OK. C'est comparable. Et donc, par exemple, on peut faire partie du Parti communiste quand on est une femme, on peut...
Ouais.
...on peut avoir des responsabilités politiques ?
Oui, oui. Oui, oui, tout à fait. Y a pas de distinction.
Et pour des choses plus anodines comme, j'sais pas, le harcèlement de rue, le sexisme, la misogynie, etc., c'est comme en Europe ?
Alors y a de la misogynie, certainement. Y a des remarques beaufs comme y en a un peu partout.
Mh.
Par contre, au niveau du harcèlement de rue, je dois dire qu'il est pratiquement inexistant en Chine. Enfin, à Shanghai et dans les quartiers les plus animés.
Je vais quand même remettre un peu les choses à leur place. Si tu vas dans des quartiers malfamés, bah ils sont pas malfamés pour rien.
Mais en Chine, c'est certainement à Shanghai, à Pékin, dans quelques villes que j'ai faites, l'endroit où je me suis sentie le plus en sécurité.
Bon, j'étais jeune, je sortais énormément, y avait beaucoup, beaucoup, beaucoup de fêtes à faire. J'ai jamais eu aucun souci, aucun regard, aucune crainte de rentrer à n'importe quelle heure de la nuit, du petit matin.
Je me suis toujours sentie vraiment beaucoup en sécurité en Chine. Déjà parce qu'il y a plein de monde dans la rue, partout et tout le temps. Et...
De jour comme de nuit ?
De jour comme de nuit. Ouais, ouais, tout à fait. Et aussi bah parce que ouais, j'ai jamais eu de regards insistants, de mains baladeuses, de... Voilà, ce harcèlement de rue que l'on connaît ici.
Moi, en tout cas, je l'ai pas connu. Alors, je sais que dans les entreprises, c'est un petit peu plus compliqué. La situation est pas parfaite, mais en tout cas, en ce qui concerne le harcèlement de rue, la Chine
est loin d'être un enfer pour les femmes.
Au contraire, c'est très agréable.
Alors, pour parler un petit peu de la langue en Chine, t'expliques qu'il y a plusieurs tons pour un même son.
Mmm-hmm. Ça génère beaucoup de blagues et beaucoup d'incompréhensions. Donc y a pas mal de Chinois qui font des blagues sur ce Français qui pensait avoir commandé une soupe et qui a reçu un plat d'intestins ou ce genre d'horreur quoi.
Ouais.
Moi, ce que je me souviens très bien, c'est que j'étais dans un resto et, les joies du choc culturel, je commande une bière et on m'apporte une bière chaude.
Donc quand même la Belge que je suis, même si j'ai jamais été une grande buveuse de bière, était trop choquée. Donc j'ai dit : « Bah est-ce que je peux avoir des glaçons ?
» Comme ça je vais mettre ma bouteille de bière dans les glaçons. Donc je répète 15 fois : « glaçon, glaçon, glaçon, bing kuai, bing kuai, bing kuai ».
Et ils me comprennent pas quoi. Donc je me retourne avec mes amis, je dis : « Est-ce que tu peux lui demander des glaçons, s'il te plaît ?
» Je lui demande en anglais. Elle dit : « Ah, c'est ça que tu demandes depuis tout à l'heure ». Et puis elle dit : « Bing kuai », donc exactement le mot que je venais de dire, mais juste avec, 'fin, une subtilité que nous, on n'entend pas quoi.
Imperceptible, ouais.
Et le serveur, il fait : « Aaah, bing kuai ! » Et il m'a amené des glaçons tout de suite quoi. Mais ça, tous les étrangers ont connu ça plus d'une fois dans leur vie.
Quand ouais, c'est très difficile à apprendre le chinois pour les tons. C'est un casse-tête parce que la grammaire est facile.
Y a quasiment pas de conjugaison. Mais par contre, donc une syllabe peut être prononcée de quatre façons différentes et avoir quatre significations différentes.
Donc puisque tu parles des restaurants, l'alimentation en Chine, on a souvent cet a priori de beaucoup d'intoxication alimentaire, 'fin de la nourriture un peu douteuse.
Est-ce qu'on mange bien en Chine ?
Alors, on mange très, très, très, très bien en Chine. Moi, j'ai un ami qui raconte toujours qu'il vit en Chine depuis 10 ans, qu'il a mangé de tous les pires trucs que tu puisses imaginer, des pattes de poulet,
des intestins dans des boui-boui, des trucs
d'une crasse monumentale.
Mais la seule fois où il a été malade, c'est quand il a mangé une pizza végétarienne quoi. Donc...
Ouais.
Donc voilà, c'est... Après, tout est frit ou cuit à l'eau bouillante quoi, donc ça tue quand même une bonne partie des germes.
C'est sûr qu'on mange pas des sushis dans la rue hein, il faut quand même de la jugeote. Donc on mange très bien en Chine.
Comme je te dis, malheureusement, les petits boui-boui tendent à disparaître. Après, y a plein de bons restos traditionnels où on peut se régaler.
Le problème des scandales alimentaires, il vient plutôt de l'agro-industrie quoi, les problèmes de lait infantile, ce genre de choses quoi.
Ouais, ouais. Donc puisqu'on parle de santé publique, je m'en voudrais de pas parler de la question du smog.
Quand t'étais dans les grandes villes, les grandes métropoles chinoises, est-ce que tu sortais ? Est-ce que t'arrivais à respirer l'air ou comment ça se passe ?
Parce qu'on a toujours en tête ces images de Shanghai avec ce brouillard, cette pollution, cet air irrespirable.
Bah les dernières années où j'étais en Chine, la dernière ou les deux dernières années où j'étais en Chine, la première chose que tu fais en te levant, c'est regarder ton appli de l'index des particules fines.
De savoir combien y a de particules fines dans l'air aujourd'hui. Et puis moi, y a eu un jour, je sais, c'était le 6 décembre parce que c'est le jour de la Saint-Nicolas et en bonne Belge, je l'ai fêté.
Et du coup, ce jour-là, j'ai su qu'il fallait que je rentre parce que là, l'indice avait explosé. L'air était jaune.
Y avait vraiment... C'était... On avait l'impression de respirer du soufre. Donc bah oui, on porte des masques, y a des purificateurs d'air dans les maisons.
C'est quand même quelque chose de difficile à accepter, de se dire, de s'infliger ça quoi. De dire : « Je me suis expatriée, mais j'ai pas envie de vivre comme ça quoi ».
Est-ce que les Chinois osent s'en plaindre auprès des autorités ou bien est-ce que...
De plus en plus.
Ouais ?
Ouais, de plus en plus.
Et ils font ça comment ?
Bah y a des manifestations, y a des protestations.
D'accord.
Je sais...
Et c'est toléré ? C'est pas immédiatement maté par les autorités ?
Bah en fait, c'est plutôt des manifestations locales. Donc en fait, bah je pense à un exemple d'un petit village où ils avaient installé une usine qui polluait la rivière du village.
Et du coup, ben, ils se... Voilà, le village s'est rebellé, a protesté, a manifesté de manière quand même très pacifiste hein.
Mais effectivement, devant la pollution, les autorités chinoises sont quand même un petit peu plus, j'aime pas dire tolérantes, mais ouais, un peu moins regardantes sur les manifestations parce qu'elles savent que
qu'il y a trop d'efforts à faire.
Comme tu dis, c'est un enjeu de santé publique. C'est quelque chose qu'elles vont devoir combattre avec l'accroissement de la population, de la consommation, et cetera.
Elles ne peuvent pas faire comme si de rien n'était quoi.
Et donc tu parles d'une usine qui polluait la rivière près d'un village.
Mmm-hmm.
Un des clichés qu'on a de la Chine, c'est qu'ils ne se préoccupent absolument pas de l'écologie.
Est-ce que c'est vrai ? Est-ce qu'on pollue sans aucun problème comme ça en Chine ? Parce que ça ne passerait pas en Europe, ce genre de comportement.
Je pense qu'on a une vision un peu idéale de l'Europe de penser que les usines ne polluent pas.
Bah le smog quand même, on n'a pas ça ici hein.
Non, non, non, non, non, c'est clair. C'est clair. Mais tu vois, faut quand même arriver à se défaire... 'Fin, faut se défaire de l'idée que tout est forcément mieux en Europe. Voilà.
Ouais.
Surtout quand moi, je suis rentrée en Europe, je me suis rendu compte que : « Ah ouais, non, c'est vrai, y avait des choses qui existent aussi chez nous ».
Pour le smog, en ce qui concerne le smog, ouais, les... Bah c'est aussi difficile en Chine qu'en Europe de changer l'industrie.
C'est... J'pense qu'ils sont plus dyna... Ils donnent l'image, ils veulent donner l'image qu'ils sont plus dynamiques, notamment en ce qui concerne la voiture électrique et la transition énergétique.
Mais c'est difficile. C'est difficile de...
Et donc quand on dit que...
Et c'est sûr qu'ils répondent pas à l'enjeu. Ça va beaucoup trop lentement.
Oui, oui. Et quand on dit que, voilà, donc la Chine qui a donc depuis des décennies ce taux de croissance monstrueux,
j'crois 10 % ou quoi, quand on dit que finalement, c'est pour la croissance, pour les rentrées économiques que ça apporte que
on y va lentement et on ne se préoccupe pas tellement de l'écologie, c'est trop simpliste ?
C'est... Y a de la vérité là-dedans ou pas ?
Y a de la vérité. J'pense que c'était vrai encore y a 10 ans. Y a 10 ans, effectivement, la croissance était encore de 10 %.
Aujourd'hui, elle est un petit peu plus faible.
Mmm-hmm.
Je pense qu'y a une frange des autorités et de la population qui se rend compte qu'il faut arrêter ce rythme effréné et qu'il faut faire une transition plus verte,
aussi parce qu'il y a beaucoup de maladies, beaucoup d'asthme, beaucoup de gens qui doivent rester chez eux.
Et donc, paradoxalement, l'économie se retrouve un peu freinée parfois par le smog. Et peut-être que c'est ça qui fera changer le plus vite encore les choses.
Alors encore deux petites questions et puis j'vais te libérer, Morgane, puisqu'on arrive au bout de cette émission.
Ouais.
Est-ce que donc on parlait donc à l'instant de
la situation économique en Chine. À un moment donné, dans le livre, tu expliques qu'il n'y a pas vraiment de classe moyenne en Chine ou en tout cas, il n'y en avait pas pendant longtemps.
Est-ce que tu peux nous expliquer un peu ça ?
Bah donc pendant les années 60, 70, 80, ouais, y avait une classe ouvrière quoi en gros, et la classe des dirigeants.
Et ce que nous, on appelle classe moyenne, effectivement, n'existait pas. Tant pas vraiment à chan... 'Fin ça change pas vraiment parce que les gens qui s'enrichissent s'enrichissent beaucoup et très vite.
Comme par exemple le patron Jack Ma de Alibaba, qui est le fils d'un marchand de crabes, je crois, et qui aujourd'hui est multimillionnaire, si c'est pas milliardaire, oui.
Donc y a cette croissance-là en Chine qui est assez impressionnante. Y a énormément de millionnaires, mais une classe mouette.
C'est pas aussi lisse en fait que chez nous où le gros de la population, on va dire, est dans la classe moyenne. Je pense pas que ce soit le cas en Chine.
De nouveau, ça fait cinq ans que je suis partie. Peut-être que je me suis pas assez penchée sur des chiffres plus récents.
Ça vaudrait le coup de regarder. Mais ce qui est sûr, c'est qu'y a encore de très fortes inégalités, beaucoup plus fortes que chez nous encore.
OK. Alors que c'est un système communiste.
Ouais. Ouais, mais qui favorise l'enrichissement personnel. C'est paradoxal. Ouais, plein de paradoxes.
Et donc, à côté de ça, quand on parle de toute cette méga croissance à Shenzhen, et cetera, en Chine, on pense beaucoup à la contrefaçon, on pense beaucoup aux copies d'idées qui viennent plutôt de l'Occident.
Est-ce qu'y a un rapport à tout ce qui est propriété intellectuelle, à la triche qui serait différent en Chine ?
Alors, en Chine, la contrefaçon n'a pas une image, une connotation négative comme elle a chez nous. Les artistes en Chine, ils vont plutôt valoriser le fait de copier un grand maître, un grand tableau.
Mmm.
Du moment que c'est bien fait, si la copie est bien réalisée, voilà, elle est digne d'être exposée, entre guillemets.
Et donc, en soi, dans la culture, déjà, le fait de copier n'a pas, voilà, cette connotation négative comme elle a chez nous.
C'est le résultat qui compte, finalement.
Voilà.
Plus que la démarche, le talent, et cetera. C'est le même résultat, donc c'est pareil.
Voilà. Alors, avec les dérives dans le secteur industriel, qui peuvent être dramatiques hein, puisqu'on copie absolument tout et n'importe quoi, des freins de voiture, des médicaments, avec plus ou moins de succès.
Et donc y a énormément de scandales liés à ça. Je sais qu'à Shanghai, y avait un cabinet français dédié à la propriété intellectuelle et
qui fonctionnait très bien parce que tous les entrepreneurs qui voulaient monter un business à Shanghai ou en Chine passaient par ce cabinet pour savoir : « Attends, est-ce que je m'associe bien avec un Chinois ?
Comment est-ce que je le fais ?
Quels sont les dangers ? » Y a une histoire assez connue de Danone qui voulait quand même pas n'importe qui hein, un géant de l'industrie agroalimentaire qui voulait s'implanter en Chine.
Pour ce faire, il a cru bon de s'associer avec un partenaire chinois dont le nom m'échappe.
Et en fait, il s'est fait voler sa recette de yaourt et Danone n'a jamais lancé de
de yaourt en Chine, mais le partenaire avec qui il s'était associé a eu beaucoup de succès et a commercialisé, on va dire, la recette de Danone sous sa propre marque.
Ça, c'est un exemple qui a 20 ans hein.
Sous le régime chinois, la priorité, c'est plutôt l'acteur chinois qui s'en sort bien et qui-
Bien sûr.
...qui amène des recettes-
...que le pauvre Danone européen qui s'est fait voler.
Voilà, c'était y a 20 ans hein, donc je suis pas sûre que ça se passerait comme ça encore aujourd'hui. Mais clairement, c'était regardé avec une certaine fierté de la part des Chinois de dire : « Bah regardez ce qu'ils ont réussi à faire.
Nous, on est vraiment intelligents hein. Nous, on a réussi à mettre un géant de l'agroalimentaire à l'envers quoi.
Donc ça prouve à quel point on est vraiment plus malins que les autres quoi. »
On les a roulés dans la farine, donc on est intelligents, on est plus malins.
Ouais.
Et alors, dernière question avant de te quitter, c'est, bah finalement, les relations amoureuses en Chine, comment est-ce que ça diffère de l'Europe ?
Et en particulier, est-ce qu'on observe beaucoup d'homophobie aussi en Chine ?
Alors, donc comme je te disais, jusqu'à y a pas très longtemps, les relations amoureuses, elles étaient très différentes de ce qu'on connaît hein, puisque
le but d'un Chinois, c'était de se marier, d'avoir une famille pour l'honneur de l'ensemble des générations précédentes.
Aujourd'hui, c'est un peu différent.
Les Chinois sont aussi fortement influencés par les comédies romantiques américaines et donc se sont créés une forme de romantisme international qui est un peu déroutant parce qu'eux-mêmes savent pas trop les codes, etc.
OK.
Donc voilà, je sais que les Français ont une très bonne, à la fois très bonne réputation et très mauvaise réputation auprès des jeunes Chinoises.
Donc voilà, l'amour, bah à l'image des relations aux autres hein, comme je te disais tout à l'heure, sont très, très différentes.
On voit beaucoup de jeunes Chinois qui portent le même t-shirt. La galanterie, ça va être plutôt de porter le sac de sa copine dans la rue plutôt que lui ouvrir la porte.
Voilà, c'est des petites choses comme ça qui sont différentes de chez nous. Ce qu'il y avait encore en Chine quand moi j'y étais, je sais pas si ça existe toujours, c'est un marché des célibataires.
Donc ça veut dire que c'est des parents qui faisaient un peu le CV de leur enfant et qui se rencontraient ensemble.
« Ah et toi, ton fils, il gagne combien ? Et moi, ma fille, elle a une voiture. Et ah ouais, mais je vais lui faire faire toutes ses dents.
» Enfin bon, ce genre de choses très dépaysantes pour nous qui avons une vision un peu plus romantique du mariage et de l'amour.
Et alors, pour te parler des droits homosexuels, ils évoluent, ils évoluent lentement. Jusqu'à 97, je crois, l'homosexualité était passible de la peine de mort.
Aujourd'hui, les lois sont plus souples hein, la peine de mort a été abolie, etc.
Ils peuvent vivre.
Oui, merci. Mais dans les mœurs, dans les faits, ouais, les homosexuels sont quand même, dans leurs droits, réduits au silence quoi.
On n'entend jamais parler de la communauté LGBT. Je crois qu'il y a eu une époque où ils ont voulu faire une Gay Pride à Shanghai.
Bon, ça s'est limité à un petit festival de films dans un cinéma indépendant où personne ne va jamais. 'Fin, c'est--
si tu veux, c'est dépénalisé, mais faut quand même pas trop qu'on se montre, qu'on les voit, qu'on-- donc les droits sont très restreints pour la communauté LGBT, ouais.
J'avais la naïveté de penser que de nouveau, cette philosophie de yin et de yang, d'équilibre, d'harmonie, tout ça, ça entre-- 'fin, ça,
ça contrevient à la culture de l'homophobie, mais t'es en train de dire que pas du tout.
Bah en fait,
si tu veux, encore, jusqu'à y a pas longtemps, on pensait que l'homosexualité, c'était une maladie. Et puis, si t'es homosexuel, bah tu vas pas te marier, tu vas pas faire d'enfants, donc tu vas pas faire honneur à ta famille quoi.
C'est tout, on revient toujours là et y a beaucoup de gens qui n'oseraient jamais faire ça à leurs parents quoi. Ce serait-- ils n'oseraient même pas quoi, ils se retiennent, c'est censuré.
Du coup, on discute de la Chine et j'ai l'impression qu'on parle de,
on parle des soucis de pollution, on parle des soucis de santé, on parle des soucis de censure, on parle de l'homophobie, on parle de toutes ces choses qui ne vont pas.
Est-ce que, Morgane, est-ce que tu peux nous expliquer pourquoi tu aimes autant la Chine ? Comment est-ce que tu expliques que tu sois tombée amoureuse de ce pays ?
Bah justement parce que c'est un voyage de tous les instants. C'est des-- on va de surprise en surprise.
Les gens sont très attachants. Les gens sont excessivement attachants. Alors moi, je dis souvent qu'on se fait pas des amis facilement, mais quand on se fait des amis, on peut vraiment compter sur eux et pour la vie.
Moi, je sais que j'ai trois amis chinois, alors on va se dire qu'en cinq ans, c'est pas grand-chose, mais j'entretiens encore des relations avec eux et on s'entend très très bien.
Y a ma meilleure amie là-bas qui a donné naissance à un petit garçon, c'est mon filleul. Donc on est très soudés.
Les relations avec les Chinois, les relations amicales sont vraiment très très très intéressantes. Après, y a les voyages puisque, ben, la Chine, c'est un continent à elle toute seule.
Donc on peut faire des découvertes, des paysages magnifiques un peu partout, même sans devoir aller très très loin de Shanghai, on voit déjà des choses superbes.
La nourriture. Alors là, moi, je suis amoureuse inconditionnelle de la cuisine chinoise. Et puis cette sensation d'être à l'aventure tout le temps quoi.
C'est génial. C'est vraiment génial.
Super. Ben alors, on espère que tu as donné envie à tous nos auditeurs et nos auditrices d'aller faire un tour en Chine.
Je crois que le billet d'avion, c'est quand même un bon 1 000 euros, donc il faut-
Ouais.
...il faut être sûr de vouloir le faire. Un dernier mot pour se quitter, un message que tu voudrais adresser à ceux et celles qui nous écoutent en ce qui concerne la Chine ?
Ben n'ayez pas peur, hein, d'y aller, allez-y. Si ça vous attire, vous serez forcément séduit. C'est une claque, la Chine, hein.
On n'est jamais indifférent, on adore et on déteste en même temps. On pense qu'on a compris quelque chose et puis le lendemain, on se rend compte que c'est totalement insaisissable.
C'est-- ça permet vraiment de grandir et de se connaître, de se connaître soi-même. Moi, je pense que ça m'a transformée en tant que personne et c'est grâce à la Chine que je suis devenue qui je suis aujourd'hui.
Et alors, pour être un petit peu moins sérieuse, c'est aussi un pays où on fait beaucoup la fête, où les gens sont super sympas.
Y a-- à Shanghai, c'est une ville qui ne dort jamais, où y a tout le temps des nouveaux bars, des nouveaux restos, et une communauté internationale très sympa.
On rencontre des gens du monde entier. Moi, j'avais des amis chiliens, néo-zélandais, de Singapour, des Français, évidemment.
Enfin, donc, c'est un mélange hyper enrichissant pour les jeunes et les moins jeunes. Faut vraiment y aller.
Super. Mais Morgane, merci beaucoup pour ce passionnant récit au sujet de la Chine.
Merci Guillaume. J'espère que j'ai pas trop raconté n'importe quoi, mais en tout cas, j'ai adoré.
Ça m'a fait vraiment plaisir de parler de la Chine avec toi et j'espère que ça plaira aux auditeurs aussi.
Plaisir partagé, en tout cas. Merci beaucoup Morgane. Au revoir.
Au revoir, bonne journée.
Voilà. Un très grand merci à Morgane pour ces 70 minutes passées ensemble. Pour rappel, son livre s'appelle Vivre la Chine et il est publié chez Ikaré Éditions.
La semaine prochaine, je recevrai nul autre que Bruno Colmant, grand intellectuel belge, professeur de finances, docteur en économie appliquée et directeur de la banque Degroof Petercam.
Ça s'annonce comme un excellent épisode. Donc ne manquez surtout pas ça. À dans deux semaines. Bye !